ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجبل وصوله للدوحه كان امها جوله اسيويه
مهمه جدا وابتسامه مع هذه الجوله في مقاطع
متداوله على تويتر لاشخاص عاشوا واندمجوا
في المجتمع السعودي ومن ابرز القصص
والمقاطع المتداوله قصه صدر الدين
الاندونيسي اللي عاش في السعوديه من 20
سنه وفي كمان طالب اندونيسي اسمه محمد
فردوس له مقطع متداول ايضا وفي بيتكلم
بعربيه فصيحه جدا عن المنحه اللي قدمت له
علشان يكمل دراسته في جامعه الملك سعود
الطبيعي و20 سنه اجلس معاكم قلبي اهل
الجيزان هذه يربطني هنا ههه
والله
انا اقول ايش لازم ازوره جيزان حتى احلى
اي مكان لازم ازور على جيزان وبعدين على
الاكلات حقه والسياحه حقه والله وربي هذا
انا اقول لك ايش انت تعرف الاندلسيه
السياحه كيف مشهور
وانهزم موجود زيه كله ثقافه واكلات واا
المكان ترى عندي بحر والله 20 سنه
شكرا يا احلى جيزان
وجيئته من دوله اندونيسيه وانا حاليا طالب
في جامعه الملك سعود بالرياض وانا متخصص
في مجال تعليم اللغه العربيه ايضا حينما
انا طالب الاندونيسي في هذه المملكه انا
استطيع ان اتعامل مع هؤلاء السعوديين في
هذه المقلب في هذه المملكه بتعامل جيد
وكريم هم ايضا يتعاملون بطريقه محبك
كمان لكوريين عايشين في السعوديه او
مندمجين مع ناسها من سنوات مثل السلوكيون
اللي بتعمل كاستاذه مساعده في قسم الهندسه
المعماريه في جامعه الامير سلطان وتخيلوا
انه في كمان رئيس لرابطه السكان الكوريين
في الرياض وهذا اسمه تصبكم وعايش في
السعوديه من اكثر من 45 سنه
[موسيقى]
في مشكله